the biggest myth that I hear about
getting a job in cyber security is that
you need to be a super technical
computer genius that's really a common
misconception the truth is we need all
kinds of people to help not just build
defenses but also deploy defenses we
need project managers cyber security
analysts security Architects all the way
up to Chief information security
officers you don't need a PhD if you've
got a Bachelor's degree in a technical
field that's a great start it could be
something like electrical or mechanical
engineering if you do have a background
in it or computer science you can be job
ready in as little as 3 months to a year
you just need the right training and
resources the foundations of information
security course that I teach as part of
Stanford online's Advanced cyber
security program is an excellent place
to start your
journey